raise your hand if your relationship
with your own body has been personally
victimized by a Victoria's Secret Angel
or runway show
the ogs like Tyra Banks or Giselle
Bundchen or the younger generation vs
Queens like Lily Aldrich Gigi or Bella
Hadid the culture of vs has left deep
marks on our generations and if it hurt
us to watch it it probably did even more
damage to walk it which is why we're now
seeing so many former Angels speaking of
so despite the magical Show sets
celebrity performances the mile long
legs and those sought after ethereal
Wings the dark underbelly of this
company and its immense power in shaping
young women psyche is now being revealed
spoiler alert this ain't good so get
your matching set on throw in some fuzzy
slippers and douse yourself in dream
Angel perfume because I'm going to be
letting some serious Secrets out of the
bag hey guys Abby here welcome to Abby's
kitchen
[Music]
um
today we're going to be talking about
the role of the Victoria's Secret Empire
in poisoning an entire generation's body
image and relationship with food a
disclaimer I will be talking about
specific Ed behaviors along with
discussions on body measurements weight
and calories so please feel free to skip
this video if it's not supportive to
your journey and if you are new here
please guys help a girl out subscribe to
the channel and ring that Bell so you
never miss out first let's talk about my
sponsor today June's Journey so everyone
who knows me knows that I love a good
murder mystery but every month I
basically plow through all my streaming
options for True Crime so as I was
waiting for something new to watch I
discovered June's Journey on my phone so
this is a really cool Hidden Object
mystery game set in the 1920s available
for free on Android and Apple mobile
devices and on desktop through Amazon or
Facebook so I actually heard about it
through someone on my team and
apparently he's got a huge following so
with more than 30 million people people
playing this thing worldwide I used to
never play games but it's kind of a nice
distraction after a really busy day that
actually requires brain and critical
thinking skills it has a solid storyline
based around the protagonist June who's
on a quest to solve the murder of her
sister and uncover her family's Secrets
the beautiful colorful Graphics are set
in the Glamorous 20s and you get the
chance to customize Remodel and fix your
mansion and Garden Island that's
actually probably my favorite part so if
you want to try out June's Journey
yourself check out the link in my
description and download the game on
Android and iOS mobile devices or
through Facebook games on your PC so for
nearly 50 years Victoria's Secret was
the only bra brand in young women's
underwear drawers and with nearly 8
million dollars in sales and a third of
the market share in its core category
during its peak it is traditionally
played a pivotal role in defining the
feminine body and that body has
traditionally been tall very thin with
large voluptuous breasts and usually not
surprisingly white one study from the
Boston University School of Medicine
found that over the past 20 years vs
models have gotten skinnier despite the
average size of a woman in the U.S
trending up trigger warning for very
specific body measurements and numbers
here but according to an article in the
globe the average Victoria's Secret
model today has an average waist size of
23.6 inches and average hit measurements
of 34.4 inches which is in stark
contrast to the size 16 to 18 body of
the average American even if these
models are genetically or naturally more
inclined to be tall and slim they're
often met with crippling pressure to
shrink their body even more my lowest
weight was 98 pounds when I was 17 and
that was after I had just done a very
successful season in Paris I don't know
I feel like I was publicly shamed
but what I was receiving for many years
was that my body was not right and it's
it's almost impossible to erase that the
rate at which this pressure results in a
clinically diagnosed eating disorder is
definitely hard to scientifically
measure since the fashion industry
traditionally normalizes and celebrates
this behavior and as a result EDS
largely go undiagnosed untreated and
virtually unseen but here are some
shocking evidence-based stats 81 percent
of models have a BMI in the underweight
category over 60 percent of models have
been told to lose weight and 21 have
been threatened to be dropped by their
agents if they don't 54 of models report
skipping meals 25 reports self-induced
vomiting and 40 report using IV drips to
offset malnourishment from lack of food
and speaking of lack of food let's
review some of the worst Victoria's
Secret quiet secrets that I have seen
reported about online
here we go again so according to the cut
American Angel Adriana Lima famously
revealed that before putting on those
wings she would cut out all solid food
live off protein shakes and water and
work out multiple times a day Georgia
Fowler told Women's Health magazine that
80 of her pre-show diet would be produce
with no carbs at all up to five days
before the show and Hungarian Angel
Barbara Palvin told W magazine that in
preparation for the show she would watch
food videos or watch her boyfriend eat
instead of eating herself wow just wow
we also really have to talk about the
revelations from industry whistleblower
and formal Aussie Angel Bridget Malcolm
so Bridget's personal Tick Tock is full
of stories about the mental and
emotional abuse that she says she
suffered at the hands of the company's
Executives she described a culture of
toxicity and misogyny in which models
were treated as mere objects with no
regard for their health or well-being
and Welcome to our new series times when
modeling has sucked the series where I
disclose publicly for the first time
times I've been attacked times have been
assaulted times have been harassed and
times where I've just been treated in a
really sub-human way I found on my bra
from the 2016 Victoria's Secret fashion
show it is a size 30A I am now a size 30
for B
which is healthy for me I was rejected
from the show in 2017 by Ed rezek he
said my body did not look good enough I
wore a size 30b at that point look how
big it was on me
the sadness behind my eyes from the 2016
showbridge Victoria's Secret your
performative ally Shep is a joke she
also revealed the strict diet and
exercise regimen that she made to stay
unimagibly thin at one point she
described herself as feeling as though
she had failed because she was living
off water for more than three days and
she kept fainting on the job so the
longest I managed to go without eating
was three days and I had to quit because
I kept passing out and I was annoyed
with myself because I was determined to
make it to five days but I I couldn't
like I couldn't function I couldn't move
and it was incredibly frustrating I
remember being so angry with myself and
feeling as though I'd failed somehow in
not being able to survive on just water
and despite all that she was still
battered to lose more weight
I'm smiling but I can I mean I know the
way I look the look in my eyes is dead I
I was dead what the [__] it honestly
blows my mind now one of the comments I
anticipate whenever I talk about
industries that reinforce problematic
body standards is that these models
signed up for the gig that they're
basically athletes and part of an
athlete's job is to maintain a specific
physique through diet and exercise and
my response to that is twofold one
water only produce protein
protein porn is not an athlete's diet
even athletes in aesthetic sports or
sports that have weight restrictions
like ballet or gymnastics would never be
advised to eat a diet like that it would
compromise their ability to do the sport
which is goal number one and I went into
a lot more detail on like an appropriate
ballerina diet here and here but you can
be damn sure folks that this ain't it
but two models are more than just
athletes or actors they're prototypes
for an image that we as a society are
buying we're seeing these bodies as an
apparent standard upon which we are held
because we're supposed to be buying the
same clothes walking in the same shoes
carrying the same purse Etc we aren't
met with images of Olympians everywhere
that we look and if we were there would
be at least some acknowledgment of their
body's role in their performance as
evidenced by Bridget Malcolm's
experience being emaciated doesn't
support a model's performance it
actually makes it a very a dangerous
game of Russian Roulette where someone
could fade fall become injured or even
die from an electrolyte depletion at any
moment of any day do you have any snacks
so it's one thing that Victoria's Secret
and the fashion industry at large is
serving to perpetuate unrealistic body
standards for young women but the
celebrity that vs has made of its Angels
brings with it a whole other dangerous
Trend and that is young girls are dying
to emulate exactly what these women eat
I mean look no further than YouTube to
see a number of first-hand examples of
girls following these vs models diets
and this is why whenever I do an eating
like video I build on problematic Trends
or meals to ensure nutrient and caloric
adequacy based on my needs I don't just
blindly eat like someone else as a
challenge like at best that doesn't make
sense and at worst it's dangerous why
the hell are content creators putting
their health at risk just to create some
content but it's not just YouTube and
Tick Tock traditional media also loves
to give vs diet tips and full out meal
plans as well like this one where they
interviewed vs diet coach whose biggest
message was do you really want this and
are you willing to accept what's
required to make it happen his
suggestion is two to four liters of
water no sugar no Dairy no processed
foods no alcohol and no carbs at all for
three to five days before a show great
love putting these messages out into the
world especially when at the end of the
interview it states wanna eat like an
angel you can with this 200 detox
honestly I know magazines need to make
money but how is this not so
irresponsible but like with most
problematic Industries people eventually
wake up and see it for what it is and
man did vs bubble ever burst fast
between 2014 and 2021 Victoria's Secret
began Fielding a ton of major
controversies including Les wexner's
connection with Jeffrey Epstein that
allegedly gave him access to vs models
countless allegations of the company's
misogyny abuse and sexual assault and
pushback over transphobic comments made
by the then CEO I've been groomed by a
much older man I've been sexually
assaulted multiple times I've been told
to to do cocaine to lose weight from my
agent I am been told whilst I was
underage to just have lots of sex to
lose weight yeah it was not good the
follow from these Revelations has been
astounding Victoria's Secret has seen a
significant loss of market share a six
percent decline in sales and about 300
store closures since 2020. to compound
these business specific controversies
their brand just started to feel really
stale we are by no means out of the
woods with diet culture in 2023 but
we've come a long way in discussions
around body positivity inclusivity and
diversity but it's as if the marketing
team at vs were coasting on the if it's
not broken don't fix it train since the
early 2000s and didn't know what to do
when it became broken Beyond repair
suddenly Brands like Aries Airy real
campaign and Savage by fenty's
iconically inclusive Fashion Show made
the Vs fashion show look super old
school and dated the show being praised
for its diversity and inclusion the
stage packed with people of all
different shapes sizes we also watched
fellow competitor third love CEO penis
spicy open letter to vs and Kim K's
skims launch a line specifically for
those with physical disabilities these
brands have been embracing a more
diverse and inclusive image of beauty
and femininity by including people of
color plus size models transgender
models and folks with disabilities so in
a recent attempt to refresh the brand
stained image and hop aboard the
inclusion Revolution oh well I tried to
start a revolution but didn't print
enough pamphlets vs brought on a whole
new female exec team and replaced the
angels with the vs Collective which is a
group of seven diverse looking women
serving as an advisory for the company
they've also been involved in
philanthropic Endeavors like starting
the Victoria's Secret Global fund for
women's cancers of course I am hopeful
and appreciative of these efforts but
I'm still not exactly fully convinced if
you go on Victoria's Secret website
today we're still looking at almost
exclusively straight-sized women some
have the classic super tone vs look and
others maybe have a softer look or like
a tiny role in their backs or their
stomachs but this is hardly an inclusive
representation of most women's bodies
it's kind of like Rebrand light so it
does feel a little bit like performative
inclusion to me the big test is going to
be with the fall return of the infamous
Victoria's Secret show and as we've
established the show is traditionally
being the Olympics for problematic Model
Behavior and displays of impossible
beauty standards so it will be telling
to see what this year's long-awaited
show will have in store I also think the
best proof of true growth would be in
acknowledging the company's problematic
past head-on we need a lot more than
just inclusivity washing to regain that
trust at least that's where I personally
am at as a consumer but I would love to
hear from you guys on your thoughts on
Victoria's Secret is the Rebrand genuine
is it too late to regain your interest
and Trust do you miss the old angel look
let me know in the comments below and on
that note that's all that I have for you
guys today if you like this video please
be sure to give it the thumbs up leave
me a comment below on what you'd like to
see me discuss next subscribe to the
channel and I'll see you next time on
Abby's kitchen bye
ha
foreign
[Music]